herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF heute live
wir blicken heute in die Ukraine seit
fast 15 Monaten wert das Land eine
Invasion ab Wert es sich gegen einen
Angriffskrieg des übermächtigen Nachbarn
Russland und wenn anfangs viele
vielleicht noch glaubten die Ukraine
wird in wenigen Tagen über Holz dann
wartet jetzt die Welt mehr oder weniger
gespannt auf die große gegen Offensive
der ukrainischen Armee wie wichtig wie
entscheidend ist diese Offensive und wo
startet sie das sind große Fragen
schwierige Fragen und wir wollen über
die ganzen Punkte sprechen mit dem
Militär Ökonom Markus käuft von der
Militärakademie der ETH Zürich wir
wollen reden mit Simon Schlegel
leitender Ukraine Analyst der
International Crisis Group beim thinking
wir erreichen Simon Schläge gleich in
uschkorod im Westen der Ukraine und wir
wollen sprechen mit unserem Reporter Tim
Kröger der ganz nah von der
bei Bach Mut berichtet
Mahmut das ist der Schauplatz der
längsten und erbitterten Gefechte die
ukrainische Armee erklärt am Sonntag
mehr als zehn Stellungen der Russen
östlich der Stadt eingenommen zu haben
das wäre der erste Vorstoß dort seit
Monaten Moskau hingegen beansprucht für
sich Gewinne innerhalb der Stadt die
russischen Soldaten kontrollieren die
Stadt bereits größtenteils
fragen wir Markus Kolb in Zürich ist das
jetzt der Beginn der großen ukrainischen
Gegenoffensive oder ist das eine Art
Vorgeplänkel
ich denke es sind verschiedene
Schauplätze die wir hier
auseinanderhalten müssen also ich habe
ja früher schon gesagt die ukrainische
gegneroffensive hat wahrscheinlich schon
begonnen allerdings würde ich die
Kampfhandlungen hier in bachmut nicht
dazu zählen was die ukrainische Gegend
Offensive sicherlich zurzeit macht ist
zum Beispiel mit den britischen
stormshadow misters die russische
Logistik sowie russische kommandozentren
hinter der Front herauszunehmen ähm also
sprich langfristig solche
Vorbereitungshandlungen erstmal
einzuführen bevor dann der mechanisierte
Durchstoß irgendwann erfolgen wird das
braucht allerdings Zeit und und gute
Vorbereitung ich denke in bachmord sehen
wir etwas anderes da sehen wir eher das
Ausnutzen einer temporären russischen
Schwäche das Problem ist folgendes als
pregorien so langsam gemerkt hat dass
seine Wagner Kämpfer zunehmend drauf
gehen und diese Leute die sind für ihn
ja kostbar nicht nur weil er ihnen viel
soll zahlt sondern weil er sie auch
teuer ausbilden muss
sagte er einfach folgendes ab sofort
werden die Flanken jetzt von einer
russischen Brigade gehalten und ich
spare mir meine Kämpfer für meine
eigenen Zwecke auf das führt nun zu dem
paradoxen Effekt dass die Russen in der
Stadt bachmut durchaus Fortschritte
machen also sie kommen so langsam voran
auch im westlichen Stadtgebiet
allerdings werden die Flanken jetzt von
schlecht ausgebildeten mobix und einer
ziemlich unprofessionell geführten
russischen Brigade gehalten deren
Kommandeure vorgestern übrigens
draufgegangen sind ja und jetzt werden
die Flanken von Norden und von Süden
aufgerollt das ist es ist eigentlich äh
paradox ja während während die Wagner
Söldner nach Westen vorstoßen werden sie
nördlich und südlich von der Ukraine
umfasst und wenn sie nicht sehr
aufpassen könnte es tatsächlich sein das
ist der Ukraine gelingt sie zu umgehen
ähm Nordlicht südlich oder sogar in
beiden Richtungen und sie damit zu
umfassen also das ist ein interessantes
Spektakel dass wir da sehen aber das hat
jetzt nicht irgendetwas zu tun mit der
eigentlichen Frühjahrsoffensive schauen
wir vielleicht gemeinsam um so ein
bisschen Orientierung zu bekommen
einfach mal auf eine Karte wir können
hier sehen das hier ist bachmut ich
hoffe wir können das einfach mal auch
auflegen wenn wir hier sehen das ist
nicht bachmut das sind bunte Streifen da
kann man nicht gerade viel erklären aber
einfach um auf die Frage jetzt immer
endlich die Karte also hier sehen wir
bachmut und was sie eben meinen ist das
brigotten hier Teile der Stadt hält oder
in die Stadt vordringt und sie eben
sagen die Flanken nördlich und südlich
dass das sozusagen das Ziel ist der
Ukrainer hier vielleicht die Armee
zurück zu
zurückzudrängen und eventuell sozusagen
einen Kreis einen Kessel zu schließen
aber die Frage an Sie ja Käufer ist man
sieht ja die diese Front ist ja
Kilometer lang und macht Mut ist eben
nur ein Steinchen was man hier sieht wo
eben schwer gekämpft hier unten haben
wir saporisch ja wir haben Harke und
viele viele andere Städte gibt es denn
Vermutung bei Ihnen wo vielleicht ein
Durchbruch dann versucht wird es gibt
auch viele andere Analysten die eben
sagen die Ukraine versucht vielleicht in
bachmut viele russische Truppen zu
binden um dann einer ganz anderen Stelle
wir haben es gerade gesehen die der von
Verlauf ist Kilometer lang hunderte
Kilometer an einer anderen Stelle dann
am Ende den Durchbruch zu schaffen wo
die Russen dann auf einmal nicht mehr so
stark aufgestellt sind
ja ich denke das auch also dieses Kalkül
russische Truppen zu binden das gilt ja
nach wie vor also nach wie vor ist der
Großteil der Kampfkraft von Wagner sowie
die Kampfkraft von zwei russischen
Brigaden in bachmut gebunden ich habe
schon häufiger darauf hingewiesen dass
das militärisch völliger Unsinn ist was
die Russen da machen also diese enormen
Kräfte nicht nur zu binden sondern auch
hin zu opfern für einen winzigen
Ausschnitt der Freund wie Sie richtig
sagen also diese gesamte Frontlinie wenn
wir die Flanken mal abziehen in der
Stadt die ist etwa 4 Kilometer Luftlinie
Nord Süd das ist also ein völliges
Missverhältnis von Ressourcen und das
führt man dazu dass die Front an anderen
Stellen einfach ausgedünn steht also
wenn wir uns mal die Strecke anschauen
zwischen saporicia und dann jetzt das
sind ungefähr 300 km und dort stehen die
Russen am dünsten und ähm ich persönlich
denke dass wenn die Ukraine einen
mechanisierten Vorstoß Unternehmen wird
also nach Abschluss dieser ganzen
Vorbereitungshandlungen nachdem man die
Logistik herausgenommen hat die und so
weiter dass sie dann dort durchstoßen
wird um die Schwarzmeerküste zu
erreichen und von dort dann die Krim
bedrohen zu können da sieht man dann ja
auf der Karte auch noch mal ganz gut
wenn man sozusagen hier in diesem
Frontverlauf zwischen saporisia und dann
jetzt was sie sagen durchstößt dann
könnte man das versteht man dann auch
als Laie sehr einfach folgendes machen
nämlich hier die Krim diesen Teil der
russisch besetzten Gebiete also die
russischen Truppen die in diesem Gebiet
sind eben von der Versorgung abschneiden
wir reden gleich noch weiter wollen aber
jetzt die Chance nutzen dass wir mit
unserem Reporter Tim Kröger sprechen
können schalten also direkt in die
Ukraine zu ihm und Tim ist im schwer
umkämpften Don was jetzt in kammertorf
er hat aber die letzten Tage
nahebach bei bachmut also ziemlich nah
an der Front berichtet gedreht und nicht
nur die Kämpfe dort sondern auch Dinge
wie das Versorgen von verletzt en
hautnah erlebt fragen wir einfach Tim
Kröger direkt Tim wie erlebst du die
Situation die wie ist die Lage die Front
bei bachmut
also wir erleben hier im Grunde genau
das gleiche was herr Kopp eben schon
gesagt hat nämlich dass hier eine sehr
paradoxe Situation eingetreten ist es
gibt unterschiedliche Entwicklungen
direkt in der Umgebung von Bach Mut auf
der einen Seite eben die russischen
Truppen die immer weiter vorstoßen im
Stadtgebiet und auf der anderen Seite
eben die ukrainischen Truppen die hier
erstmals seit Monaten eigentlich an den
Rändern also an den Flanken von bachmut
vormarschieren können das was wir hören
ist dass das wohl bis zu 20
Quadratkilometer gewesen sind ein
Geländegewinn die sie in den letzten
Tagen verzeichnet haben heute haben wir
noch einmal gehört dass sie noch mal
weitere 500 Meter vorangekommen sind und
das ist schon bemerkenswert das ist
jetzt eben ein solchen Vorstoß seitens
der Ukraine gibt und ich möchte
vielleicht noch ergänzen dass wir auch
hier
öfters von Soldaten gehört haben dass
das ganze auch einem psychologischer
Moment ist der da auf die russischen
Truppen einwirkt nämlich dass sie ja
wirklich monatelang versucht in Richtung
der ukrainischen Truppen vorzurücken
aber eben wirklich nur sehr sehr langsam
wenn auch stetig vorangekommen sind und
das jetzt innerhalb weniger Tage die
ukrainischen Truppen wohl doch relativ
ich sage mal gute Fortschritte gemacht
haben und dass das eben zum einen die
ukrainischen Truppen natürlich beflügelt
und die bestärkt das ist auf der anderen
Seite aber eben die russischen Truppen
durchaus auch ja demoralisiert das
könnte sich vielleicht auch auf weitere
Kampfhandlungen dann im Zuge einer
Gegenoffensive der Ukraine womöglich
auswirken und du hast es gesagt wir
waren hier in den vergangenen Tagen rund
um bachmut unterwegs und wir haben dabei
auch mit einem Kommandeur der eine
Einheit der 28 Brigade gesprochen der
hier vor allem mit seiner Einheit die
Luftüberwachung übernimmt
das bedeutet sozusagen dass er Drohnen
in der Luft hat die dann der Artillerie
am Boden hilft bereits identifizierte
russische Stellung anzugreifen sozusagen
sich immer näher in das Ziel
heranzutasten wir waren dann einer
Werkstatt und haben dort auch gesehen
wie im Grunde sie mit handelsüblichen
Drohnen die man im Geschäft kaufen kann
dass diese bestückt worden sind mit
selbst gebauten
Sprengkörpern und dass diese sogenannten
Kamikaze drohen dann eben in ziemlich
hinein geflogen werden so operiert diese
Einheit und dieser kann man der hat uns
eben erzählt dass bei diesem Zangengriff
der da gerade entsteht tatsächlich das
Ziel ist eben am Ende die Truppen in
bachmut ein für die russischen Truppen
im bachmut zum Singen einzukesseln und
ein hoher ukrainischer Militär hat hier
auch gesagt dass die ukrainischen pardon
die russischen Truppen dort mittlerweile
eigentlich in einer Art Mausefalle
stecken
also dann bestätigt er das was eben Herr
Kolk ja auch gesagt hat sozusagen ein
Vorrücken über die Flanken und es droht
letzten Endes dann eine Einkesselung der
russischen Truppen ins Wagner Truppen
die eben in bachmut vorrücken jetzt hast
du gestern aber auch bei einer
ukrainischen sanitätseinheit gedreht und
was diese Soldaten also die Sanitäter ja
auch Tag für Tag Woche für Woche erleben
und aushalten müssen dass hast du sehr
eindrücklich in Bildern festgehalten und
das wollen wir uns gemeinsam anschauen
es ist ein ruhiger morgen für die
ukrainische Einheit am evakuierungs- und
erste-hilfepunkt nur wenige Kilometer
hinter der Front von bachmuth die
Sanitäter und Ärzte versorgen hier
verwundete Soldaten damit sie für den
Transport zur Weiterbehandlung stabil
sind
immer auf Standby weil in der 1 Minute
eine Person in der anderen minute aber
10 Personen gebracht werden können
am Mittag dann ist das passiert was sie
hier schon so viele Male erleben mussten
ein gepanzertes Fahrzeug bringt einen
Soldaten der an der Front durch
Schrapnelle verletzt wurde
er hat einen offenen Bruch am Bein und
sein Unterarm ist verletzt wir haben ihn
versorgt und Infusion gegeben
24 Stunden dauert eine Schicht immer
wieder ist entfernt der Gefechtslärm zu
hören aber immerhin rund 95% der
Verwundeten könnten sie retten sagen sie
der 28-Jährige ihor ist seit einem
halben Jahr im Einsatz jeder Handgriff
muss jetzt sitzen Emotionen kann er sich
nicht leisten ich mache nur meinen Job
und ich weiß was ich zu tun habe jeder
muss seine Aufgabe in diesem Krieg
erfüllen
das ist auch für die medizinischen
Helfer und Helferinnen gefährlich denn
die evakuierungspunkte selbst können
Ziel von Angriffen werden
ich träume wie jeder in der Armee davon
zu meiner Familie zurückzukehren gesund
und leben und so tun Sie alles damit so
viele Soldaten und Soldatinnen wie
möglich den Krieg überstehen gesund und
leben
also da läuft zu einem also mir
zumindest schon ein bisschen in den
Rücken runter jetzt gibt es Luftalarm
erstmal die Frage Tim musst ihr jetzt
die Straße verlassen
nein also nach meiner Einschätzung wir
haben hier in Kanadas wirklich im
halbstündigen Rhythmus Luftalarm können
wir diese Scheiße durchaus noch zu Ende
bringen okay also sicherheit geht vor
kein Thema wenn ihr Weg müsst wie gesagt
das sind sehr eindrückliche Bilder
gewesen die wir gerade gesehen haben Tim
was macht das denn mit dir wenn du das
miterlebst was die Sanitäter da machen
naja also das war gestern bei diesem
Dreh schon eine sehr eindrückliche
Situation es ist ja so dass wir alle
jeden Tag diese Nachrichten aus bachmut
aus den vergangenen Monaten gehört haben
wir haben immer diese kryptischen Zahlen
von diesen vielen Toten und Verletzten
gehört und das war eben das erste mal
dass das Team wir als Team hier dort
wirklich ein verwundeten Soldaten
gesehen haben also ein Einzelschicksal
ein Menschen der womöglich in dieser
Verletzung die er da hatte sein ganzes
Leben operieren wird also er wird
wahrscheinlich sein ganzes Leben mit
diesem Krieg folgen jetzt zu tun haben
und auf der anderen Seite was ich auch
sehr beeindruckend fand das war
natürlich diese medizinischen
Helferinnen und Helfer die dort an
diesem sogenannten Evakuierungspunkt
waren die dort in 24 Stunden Schichten
wirklich jederzeit auf Standby sind
bereit sind sofort aufzuspringen und
dann diese zum Teil wirklich schweren
Verletzungen zu behandeln um eben diese
Verbündeten Soldaten dann so weit zu
stabilisieren dass sie weiter
transportiert werden können in die
Krankenhäuser wo sie dann eben von
professionellen Ärzten Chirurgen und so
dann noch mal richtig behandelt werden
zum anderen gibt es in diesen
evakuierungspunkten auch immer wieder
die Situation dass gefallene Soldaten
dort angebracht werden und dann müssen
diese
medizinischen Helferinnen und Helfer
halt erstmal feststellen woran dieser
Soldat gestorben ist wir müssen die
gefallenen Soldaten dann auch bereit
machen für den Weitertransport und wenn
man sich vorstellt was das mit einem
Menschen Macht dann war es wirklich
beeindruckend zu sehen mit welcher
Professionalität und Ruhe eben doch
diese Helfer versuchen da zunächst
einmal ihre Pflicht zu erfüllen und dann
eben womöglich erst in einem ruhigen
Moment darüber nachzudenken was sie da
alles erlebt haben
jetzt kann man eigentlich nicht
vergessen was e-hor dir da gesagt hat
dass er zu dir ja gesagt hat ich wir
alle wir träumen davon endlich nach
Hause zurück zu kehren lebend und gesund
wie lange fragt man sich automatisch
müssen die Ukrainer denn davon noch
träumen was sagen auch diese Sanitäter
zu dir sagen Sie es ist fürchterlich was
wir hier durchmachen was wir alles
tagtäglich erleben aber wir machen das
weiter bis sozusagen alle besetzten
Gebiete befreit sind die Russen aus dem
Land vertrieben sind oder gibt es da
auch welche die Seufzen zu dir sagen ich
hoffe nur dass bald Frieden ist und wenn
wir einfach jetzt die Waffen niederlegen
und vielleicht die Krim verlieren aber
Hauptsache es ist Schluss mit diesem
töten
also ich weiß nicht was in den Herzen
und den Köpfen der Soldaten wirklich vor
sich geht aber
wir hören in den meisten Fällen und das
halte ich auch für absolut authentisch
dass die meisten Soldatinnen und
Soldaten Helferinnen und Helfer alle die
einer Front aber auch im dahinter
agieren in dieser Armee tatsächlich
davon überzeugt sind dass sie hier
durchhalten müssen bis am Ende ein Sieg
herum ist und ich höre tatsächlich
meistens dass dieser sieht so aussehen
wird dass die gesamte das gesamte Gebiet
der Ukraine komplett befreit werden muss
das wirklich erst wenn der letzte
russische Soldat die Gebiete der Ukraine
verlassen hat dass dann der Krieg für
Sie vorbei ist das ist zumindest das was
wir im Moment hören aber natürlich
dieser Krieg dauert jetzt schon weit
mehr als ein Jahr was wir auch hören ist
dass die Menschen dass die Soldaten alle
mittlerweile sehr erschöpft sind nicht
das ist doch eine permanente psycholog
Belastung es ist die Angst um
Familienmitglieder um Angehörige Väter
Töchter Söhne also man kann sich das
schwer vorstellen was das mit den
Menschen hier macht das ist übrigens
nicht nur hier vorne an der Front so
sondern das ist beispielsweise auch in
Kiew so in Kiew muss man sich vorstellen
ist das Leben mittlerweile fast normal
zumindest äußerlich es ist früh
sommerlich es ist grün geworden in Kiel
die Leute sind in den auf den Straßen
sind in den Café sie sitzen in den
Restaurants aber sofort wenn man
irgendetwas tiefer guckt dann mit den
Leuten spricht merkt man dass jeder in
seinen Gedanken immer bei diesem Krieg
ist oder zumindest sehr sehr häufig und
dann natürlich nachts kommen die
Angriffe die Angriffswellen aus der Luft
aus Russland die dann natürlich den
Krieg auch in Kiel wieder gegenwärtig
machen
Tim dann denken wir ganz ganz herzlich
für diese sehr eindrücklichen und sehr
persönlichen ja Schilderungen und
Wünschen weiter alles Gute das ist
vielleicht doch noch eine ruhige Nacht
wird vielen
ja wir bleiben in der Ukraine gehen
jetzt aber von kremators nach uschkorod
das ist ganz im Westen der Ukraine
direkt an der slowakischen Grenze Simon
Schlegel ist leitender Ukraine Analyst
eines Think Tanks mit dem Namen
International Crisis Group dieser Think
Tank hat seinen Sitz in Belgien Simon
Schlegel lebt und arbeitet aber seit
2017 schon in der Ukraine eigentlich in
Kiew von ist aus Sicherheitsgründen
jetzt in uschko rot ich grüße ganz
herzlich er Schlägel alle Welt redet
alle Welt wartet auf die Gegend
Offensive der ukrainischen Armee und am
Donnerstag sagt selensky gegenüber der
BBC die Ukraine brauche noch Zeit bis
weitere Waffenlieferungen aus dem Westen
da sind wie steht es denn nun um diese
Offensive sind die Erwartungen am Ende
vielleicht auch zu hoch was die
ukrainische Armee leisten kann
ja ich glaube es in letzter Zeit die
Erwartungen an diese Gegenoffensive sich
so ein bisschen hochgeschraubt haben in
der Öffentlichkeit vor allem im Westen
dass wir sehr hohe Ziele gesteckt haben
und jetzt eben die Ukraine selber ein
bisschen das abdämpfen müssen damit
diese damit das Ergebnis dann nicht zu
harsch bewertet wird also selenski hat
das im Nachgang dazu gemacht dass zum
Beispiel sein Verteidigungsminister das
schon mal so formuliert hat dass die
Erwartungen sehr hoch geworden sind und
das der Erfolg dieser gegen Offensive
überhaupt nicht garantiert ist denn es
ist ja ein sehr
gefährlicher
eine sehr gut gesicherte Frontlinie
durch die die urina durchbrechen müssen
sie müssen das machen mit neuen Gerät
mit einer
großer Anzahl erst ganz frisch
trainierter Soldaten viele davon den
besten trainiert das heißt es steht auch
sehr viel auf dem
will was politischer Rückhalt in der
Ukraine selber und im Westen betrifft
und deswegen ist diese Vorsicht jetzt
die jetzt von selenski ganz von oben
kommt sicherlich auch
angebracht und hat eben auch den Zweck
das Feld zu bereiten falls der Erfolg
jetzt nicht so durchschlagend ist wie
das viele annehmen der größte Erfolg
wäre natürlich ein Durchbrechen an die
Küste des Asowschen Meeres was wir
vorher nach der Karte gesehen haben dass
würde ein Durchbrechen durch mehrere
sehr gut gesicherte Verteidigungslinien
der Russen bedeuten wo in einem Gebiet
wo die urkinder gar keine Lufthoheit
haben das heißt sie sind während sie
diese Linien versuchen zu überwinden
werden sie Minen räumen müssen während
sie schützen heben ähm
überwinden müssen sind sie die ganze
Zeit unter Artillerie Beschuss und unter
Luftangriffen und was sie ganz in diesem
Interview gesagt hat ist ja auch dass
der
der Preis im Moment zu hoch wäre und
hier geht es eben genau um die Ankunft
von mehr gepanzerten Fahrzeugen in denen
die Soldaten besser geschützt sind und
es geht eben auch um die Ankunft von
Waffen mit einer längeren Reichweite mit
denen die Versorgungslinien der
russischen Armee unterbrochen werden
können so dass diese
Verteidigungsanlagen dann weniger gut
versorgt werden können mit Munition mit
Treibstoff und auch mit Soldaten und
dass ich dann an der einen oder anderen
Stelle vielleicht eine Lücke auftut wo
die urena eine Chance haben ohne
allzu schlimme Verluste und ohne
eingekesselt zu werden diese Linien zu
durchbrechen ob das gelingt
ist auch nach der Ankunft des dieser
letzten Neuigkeiten von letzter Woche
der Mittelstrecken Raketen natürlich
nicht garantiert aber es ist
wahrscheinlich geworden
also sagen sie ja in der Tat wenn
selensky sagt wir müssen noch warten die
Ukraine braucht noch Zeit Geduld dann
hat das schon seine Begründung weil sie
eben sagen es braucht noch Munition es
braucht mehr Vorbereitung weil ansonsten
eine offensive am Ende sozusagen ein
blutgemetzelt wird und die Verluste
vielleicht auch auf ukrainischer Seite
zu hoch werden wenn selenski jetzt aus
diesen sehr rationalen nachvollziehbaren
Gründen sagt bitte noch Geduld auch die
Erwartung nicht zu hoch wie sieht es
aber sie leben in KF sie sind jetzt in
urort wie ist denn aber die ja die
Gefühle wir sind die Gefühle wie ist die
Erwartungen wie sind die Hoffnungen denn
der Ukrainer der Bevölkerung der
Menschen mit denen sie sprechen ich habe
Tim Krüger ja gerade schon gefragt ist
die Moral so stark dass die Ukraine
sagen wir ziehen das durch auch nach
fast 15 Monaten wir sind dann erst bei
dem Punkt wo wir sagen Frieden die
Waffen schweigen wenn der letzte Ukraine
ukrainischen wenn der letzte Russe
ukrainischen Boden verlassen hat wenn
wir also alle besetzten Gebiete befreit
haben oder ist es so dass es eben eine
Müdigkeit gibt und dass sie Menschen
sagen wir wollen endlich Frieden und sei
es zu dem Preis dass wir die dass wir
die Krimi aufgeben sei es zu dem Preis
dass es manche Gebiete gibt ihm dann was
die wir an Russland abtreten wie ist da
so diese Stimmung
man hört eigentlich in der Ukraine gar
nie eine andere Definition des Sieges
oder des Ausgang des Krieges überhaupt
als das was die geschildert haben dass
wirklich die ganze russische Armee sich
vom ganzen ukrainischen Gebiet in den
Grenzen von 1991 zurückziehen muss
es ist auch wenn sie jetzt schauen woher
die Ukraine kommt in diesen 15 Monaten
was ich alles getan hat in dieser Zeit
wir haben in einer Situation angefangen
jetzt diese Inversion wo viele glaubt
haben dass hier in drei Tagen fahren
würde und Putin dort eine Siegesparade
abhalten würde und das nachher russische
Soldaten von Tür zu Tür gehen würden von
dieser Situation haben wir es uns dahin
bewegt und die russische Armee es als
großen Erfolg feiert wenn Sie einen
Straßen fährt in bachmut im mit vielen
Verlusten und über Wochen hin
erobert wir sind von einer Situation
gekommen in der viele westliche
Politiker Angst hatten Anti panzerwaffen
in die Ukraine zu schicken zu jetzt zu
einer Diskussion wo es ernsthaft darum
geht Kampfjets an die Ukraine zu
schicken wir sind von einer Situation
gekommen wo viele eigentlich der
urischen Armee gar keine Erfolgschancen
eingeräumt haben zu jetzt wo die ganze
Welt erwartet dass die ukrainische Armee
den ganzen Süden des Landes aufräumt in
einem
Aufwisch das ist ein sehr sehr großer
Weg den die Ukrainer zurückgelegt haben
viele zu einem sehr sehr hohen
persönlichen Preis und das Leben ja in
der Ukraine fast 5 Millionen interne
vertriebene die nach Hause wollen es
gibt sehr viele Familien die jemanden
Krieg verloren haben oder Verletzungen
erlitten haben die einen hohen
persönlichen Preis bezahlt haben
deswegen ist das Handtuch zu werfen
jetzt in dieser Situation überhaupt
nicht in der Luft würde ich sagen es
gibt dazu auch Umfragen regelmäßig
sagen mehr als 90% der Ukraine das sie
an den Sieg der Ukraine glauben es gibt
da Unterschiede zwischen dem Osten
Landes wo der Krieger schon neun Jahre
dauert und im Westen aber es sind
minimale Unterschiede es gibt auch
Unterschiede zwischen Leuten die zu
Hause russisch sprechen und die zu Hause
Ukraine sprechen aber auch da es geht um
ein paar Prozentpunkte die überwiegende
Mehrheit erwartet von der Politik und
erwartet von sich selber dass sie diesen
Krieg gewinnen und
ob die gegen Offensive jetzt im Mai oder
im Juni oder ist im August startet wird
daran wahrscheinlich wenig Rücken im
Gegenteil ist es wahrscheinlich ein
Zeichen dafür dass es nicht jetzt blinde
Politik ist dass man irgendwelche ein
symbolisches Datum einhalten muss
sondern dass der Präsident des Landes
auch auf die Armeeführung hört und
versucht rationale Entscheidung treffen
die es ihm erlauben dann Erfolge zu
erziehen die einen angemessenen Preis
eben an Menschen leben und auch an
Verlust an dieser Technik dieser neuen
Waffen die auch mit viel Geduld jetzt
errungen wurden gewisse
leistungserhaltung
da bleibt oder eben auch wenn jetzt
diese Offensive nicht zu einem
Durchschlag mehr Erfolg wird eine
nächste Etappe noch möglich ist
damit sagen sie eben das was andere
Analysten ja eben auch sagen warum muss
es überhaupt eine große Offensive geben
es kann einen anderen kleineren
Schritten sein Herr Schlegel ganz ganz
herzlichen Dank wie sie das erklärt
haben einerseits warum man Geduld haben
muss die Worte von selenski wie sie zu
interpretieren sind und eben auch wie
die Haltung der Ukrainer eben ist das
ist sehr sehr interessant und bestätigt
das was dem eben auch gesagt hat Herr
Schlegel vielen vielen Dank liebe Grüße
und ein großes Dankeschön nach Gott
ja soweit direkt Stimmen Bilder
Eindrücke aus dem Kampfgebiet aus der
Ukraine die Ukraine war aber heute auch
Thema im Wald entfernten Island in der
isländischen Hauptstadt Reykjavik kam
heute der Europa-Rat zusammen es ging um
einen schadensregister also wie Russland
in der Zukunft mal für die Zerstörung in
der Ukraine zur Kasse gebeten werden
kann es ging am Rande aber auch noch um
viel mehr denn der britische Premier und
der niederländische Ministerpräsident
haben gesagt sie wollen sie planen eine
Kampfjet Koalition für die Ukraine
treffen sich gestern Abend zwei
Regierungschefs der eine aus den
Niederlanden hat F16 Kampfjets der
andere aus Großbritannien könnte Piloten
daran ausbilden lassen im Anschluss
erklärt ein Sprecher des Briten beide
hätten vereinbart eine internationale
Koalition aufzubauen um die Ukraine mit
kampfflugzeugkapazitäten auszustatten
von der Ausbildung bis zur Beschaffung
von F16 Jets westliche F16 Kampfjets es
wäre die nächste Stufe der militärischen
Unterstützung der Ukraine das was die
seit Monaten fordert diverse
NATO-Staaten haben diese Jets im Bestand
nicht aber Deutschland also liefert man
auch keine Kampfjets sagt der Kanzler
heute
in Hinblick auf uns sind keine
Anforderungen da wir haben uns darauf
konzentriert und konzentrieren uns auf
das was wir tun sprich Panzer und
Luftabwehr um Kampfjets kümmern sich
andere der niederländische premiermark
rütte zurückhaltend positiv
wir können erst dann etwas ankündigen
wenn es auch fertig ist aber wir bauen
an einer Koalition mit Ländern die mit
uns darüber nachdenken wie das möglich
wäre
jetzt also auch westliche Kampfjets je
länger Russland sein im Krieg führt
desto mehr rote Linien des Westens
fallen offenbar noch aber steht diese
Kampfjet Koalition nicht noch fehlt vor
allem die Zusage des wichtigsten
naturlandes die Zusage aus den USA auch
dort wird jetzt intensiv abgewogen wie
groß wäre der militärische nutzen und
wie groß das Risiko einer Eskalation
sehr knifflige Fragen und über die
wollen wir reden eben mit unserem
militär-experten von der Militärakademie
ETH Markus wie wahrscheinlich ist es
denn jetzt erst einmal dass die Ukraine
F16 Kampfjets westliche Kampfjets also
bekommt und das ukrainische
Piloten eben mit westlichen Maschinen ja
russische Truppen angreifen können
also ich denke man sollte da erstmal
ansetzen bei diesem sogenannten Begriff
der roten Linien meinen Kopf wird immer
so ein bisschen rot wenn ich diesen
Begriff höre es gibt keine roten Linien
es gibt nur russische Täuschungsmanöver
sage ich immer wir erinnern uns noch mal
ne die Diskussion die wir im Mai 22 also
vor etwa einem Jahr geführt haben hat
sollen wir wirklich diese schrecklich
aggressive Artillerie an die Ukraine
liefern das sind ja dann keine
Verteidigungswaffen und überhaupt
beginnt und so weiter und so weiter was
ist passiert genau sie sehen also dass
der Westen seine naja sie können es
jetzt Besonderheit nennen oder Feigheit
auf jeden Fall sagen wir mal seine
Zurückhaltung so langsam aufgeht und
erkennt worum es sich bei diesem Krieg
wirklich handelt nämlich um einen
imperialen Eroberung Trikot Russlands
und das entsprechende Mitte eingesetzt
werden müssen um denen rückgängig zu
machen das wird jetzt hoffentlich auch
noch den letzten besonnenen Menschen
klar nun ist es tatsächlich so dass
nicht alle Nationen die F16 haben
aber ja wie ich bin nicht ganz so
glücklich mit dem Beitrag weil die
wichtigsten Beitrag haben die USA
bereits geleistet nämlich dass sie
dieser Koalition nicht widersprechen das
könnten sie nämlich mit dem Argument das
ist ein amerikanisches Waffensystem und
wir genehmigen nicht dass das eingesetzt
wird
Großbritannien und insbesondere die
Niederlande haben schon vor längerem
also schon Ende März solche Bemerkungen
fallen lassen dass sie es sich
vorstellen könnten F16 zu liefern also
ich denke das kommt jetzt nicht von
heute auf morgen sondern das ist von
langer Hand vorbereitet auch Belgien hat
seit gestern schon angekündigt sie
werden Piloten daran ausbilden das hat
natürlich auch für andere Nationen den
wunderbar gesichtswaren Defekt dass man
jetzt sagen kann wunderbar wir brauchen
ja gar nicht liefern weil zum Glück
haben wir keine F16 also vermutlich ist
das in der Rammstein Gruppe so ein
bisschen abgesprochen worden dass da
jeder sein Gesicht waren kann und dass
man eben trotzdem
militärisch das tut was notwendig ist
und die russische Aggression zu
neutralisieren also sprich die Frage ist
nicht mehr dass die Ukraine F16 bekommt
sondern wann und wie viele da passt die
Frage wir haben viele Fragen jetzt
direkt an Sie Herr Kolb ein User
schreibt sind die F16 denn sinnvoll
zurzeit einzusetzen da es keine klare
Luftüberlegenheit gibt also was würden
jetzt F16 Kampfjets helfen was würden
Sie verändern wie würden sie das Blatt
irgendwie wenden
also es gibt im wesentlichen drei Gründe
für den F16 also das erste ist was was
der User zunächst mal selber anspricht
nämlich die Luft Überlegenheit es ist
nach wie vor so das russische
Kampfflugzeuge relativ ungestraft im
ukrainischen Luftraum operieren können
solange sie sich nicht allzu nahe der
ukrainischen Luftabwehr annähern das
heißt ein großes Problem für die Ukraine
ist immer noch das russische Kampfjet
überhaupt in ihrem Luftraum eindringen
und von dort aus äh Körper abschießen
können also das könnte man zunächst mal
wieder mit 16 deutlich re investieren
indem es einfach wieder zu Lust kämpfen
käme also indem die Ukraine glaubwürdig
auch ihre eigene Luft Hoheit durchsetzen
könnte das zweite was man auch sehen
muss ist die Ukraine kämpft im Moment
mit Systemen deren Lebensdauer und deren
Durchhaltefähigkeit zu neige geht
nämlich im Prinzip mit Ex sowjetischen
Systemen also der mic-familie sowohl mit
ihren eigenen Flugzeugen wie auch mit
Flugzeugen die zum Beispiel Polen
geliefert hat aber man muss klar sagen
das ist die Technologie der ehemaligen
Sowjetunion die geht nicht nur aus aus
Zeit historischen Gründen zu Ende
sondern auch weil ein Kampfflugzeug
einfach eine begrenzte
Anzahl an Flugstunden hat die es
überhaupt als militärischer Effektor zu
gebrauchen ist das heißt wenn man jetzt
nichts machen würde dann würde sich
einfach die ukrainische Luftwaffe über
die Zeit abnutzen und irgendwann würde
die Ukraine ohne Luftwaffe darstellen
also dann ein technologischer Ersatz ist
auf jeden Fall notwendig und da macht es
natürlich Sinn auch im Sinne der der
militärischen Zukunft der Ukraine und
der NATO Mitgliedschaft die sich auch
ankündigt dass man eben auf westliche
Systeme wechselt der dritte Punkt ist
dass die F16 eigentlich das beste
abschlusssystem für die sogenannte jdms
Munition ist das ist also das was ich
früher mal als ikea-bausatz bezeichnet
habe also man kann damit normale Bomben
umrüsten zu Präzisionswaffen das ist
also ein Heck dass man dran schraubt und
gleitflügel oben dran und diese jdms das
ist eben eine Waffe die von
Kampfflugzeugen aus eingesetzt wird
und es gibt eben den den sehr großen
Vorteil anders als z.B bei der
Artillerie Munition das ist derzeit eine
halbe Million von diesem Pilz weltweit
gibt also die werden schon seit bald 25
Jahren produziert das heißt hier haben
wir insbesondere das nicht was wir immer
bei der Artillerie thematisieren nämlich
Munitionsmangel wenn Sie das äh zusammen
nehmen dann würde das die Ukraine sicher
auf dem neuen Level militärische
Fähigkeiten heben
also klare Argumente und Gründe warum
die F16 einen ja ein Blatt wenden kann
oder eine große Rolle spielen kann
weitere sehr interessante
strategestechnische Frage Legolas
schreibt fragt warum hat die Ukraine die
krimbrücke mit Storm Shadow noch nicht
angegriffen und Carsten Conrads fragt
macht eine Gegend Offensive überhaupt
Sinn so lange über die Couch Brücke noch
Nachschub rollen kann
ja zur kerzbrücke werde ich relativ
häufig gefragt also ich denke das kann
man mit zwei Argumenten umfassen zum
einen denke ich dass wenn die kernbrücke
angegriffen wird dann wird es der
Schlusspunkt der gegen Offensive sein
weil ich denke die Ukraine wird Russland
bis zum Schluss eine exit Option offen
lassen weil wenn sie glaubwürdig drohen
kann die Südfront einzunehmen oder die
Frauen zu spalten dann denke ich ist es
sinnvoll den Russen eine Möglichkeit
offen zu lassen wie sie ihre Truppen
abziehen können und dafür brauchen sie
die Brücke von das ist die einzige
Landverbindung nach Russland hinein wenn
man in dieser Option nicht geben würde
dann wären sämtliche Truppen auf der
Creme gefangen die schwarzen Flotte ist
logistisch nicht in der Lage die zur
evakuieren das heißt dann müsste man sie
zusammenschließen und es ist denke ich
für die Ukraine eleganter diese Option
bis zum Schluss offen zu lassen weil es
dann nämlich eine Entscheidung der
Russen ist ob sie ihre Reserven sinnlos
opfern oder ob sie sich freiwillig
zurückziehen das ist also durchaus eine
Möglichkeit den Krieg früher zu beenden
ist eigentlich paradox indem man die
Brücke nicht beschießt beendet man den
Krieg früher aber ich denke dass es sich
an Motiv dass da hinein spielt wenn Sie
die Logistik ansprechen für die Logistik
ist es vor allem entscheidend dass sie
nicht aus der Krim herauskommt also
sprich es ist weniger schlimm wenn in
die Creme über die die Brücke von
Körbchen Lieferungen kommen aber sie zum
Beispiel das Eisen bei den
Eisenbahnknoten bei John Koi
herausnehmen oder die sagen wir die die
verschiedenen Luftblasen die es gibt auf
der Creme von der aus Angriffe geflogen
werden das wäre sehr viel wirksamer weil
dann würde die Südfront und auch die Don
was Front größtenteils ohne Nachschub da
stehen und relativ schnell kollabieren
jetzt haben sie einen Punkt ja schon
angesprochen dass
einerseits oder wir haben es ja auch
schon gehört dass selenski
wahrscheinlich versucht und vielleicht
auch mit einer Offensive noch ein
bisschen wartet bisher gepanzerte
Fahrzeuge da sind um eben vielleicht
auch eigene Verluste zu verhindern oder
damit sie nicht so groß werden Martin
Schmidt fragt jetzt hier zu den
Verlusten auf beiden Seiten weiß
eigentlich irgendjemand irgendwie genau
wie viele ukrainische Soldaten bisher
getötet wurden
also wenn wir zunächst noch auf den
vorigen Punkt eingehen man muss sich
immer eines klar machen dass die Ukraine
eine eine sehr erfolgreiche
desinformationsstrategie betreibt was
ihre Offensive angeht zu hören also
äußerst widersprüchliche Töne mal heißt
es wir haben schon begonnen mal heißt es
nein der Boden ist noch zu schlammig mal
heißt es ja erwarte bloß nicht zu viel
mal heißt es doch doch wir werden ganz
sicher demnächst durchbrechen ähm das
ist denke ich Teil einer bewussten
Verwirrung die vor allem Darts darauf
zielt sowohl die russischen Spione bzw
Kollaborateure als auch mögliche
undichte Stellen im Ausland einfach zu
verwirren und bis zum Schluss im
Unklaren zu lassen wann genau was
geschieht ich denke man sollte dann
nicht allzu sehr auf diese politischen
narrative hören weil das ist letztlich
na ja Propaganda sondern worauf man
schauen muss ist das was tatsächlich
passiert am Boden in der Luft und daraus
seine Schlussfolgerung ziehen und das
heißt für mich doch ich höre sehr sehr
wenig auf diese ganzen politischen
narrative oder diese Ankündigungen von
irgendwelchen Leuten die sich hinstellen
und sagen demnächst passiert dies
demnächst passiert das es zur zweiten
Frage ist gibt tatsächlich Schätzungen
der ukrainischen Verluste also von den
US-amerikanischen Geheimdiensten die
sagen etwa 30.000 was überraschend wenig
ist also kill den Action wenn Sie das
vergleichen mit den gesamten russischen
Verlusten die mindestens doppelt so hoch
liegen und dazu kommt es und das weil es
interessant wegen ihres Beitrags dazu
kommt eine deutlich schlechtere ähm
sanitätsleistung der Russen das heißt
also wenn ein Russe auf dem Schlachtfeld
auf nur leicht verwundet wird dann ist
die Chance relativ hoch dass er trotzdem
stirbt einfach weil er nicht evakuiert
wird er wird einfach liegen gelassen
oder bei dem Hinterland die die
Sanitätsversorgung einfach viel zu
schlecht ist und das führt dazu dass
Russland nicht nur ein höheren Anteil
verwundete hat sondern auch dass viele
diese Verwundeten eben nicht wieder für
den Krieg zur Verfügung stehen sondern
sterben oder dauerhaft invalid bleiben
und wenn Sie das Zusammenrechnen und
dann kann man mittlerweile davon
ausgehen dass die ursprüngliche
russische Invasionsarmee von etwa
170.000 Mann weitgehend außer Gefecht
gesetzt ist und jetzt zunehmend durchs
ersetzt worden ist also durch
mobilisierte die gar nicht oder nur
schlecht ausgebildet sind und das muss
man eben im Hinterkopf haben wenn man
sich diese diese Verlust raten anschaut
also nicht nur wie sind die jetzt weil
die spiegeln im Wesentlichen die
vergangenen 12 Monate der Krieg Führung
wieder sondern wie werden die sich in
Zukunft entwickeln und auch da neigt
sich die Waagschale deutlich auf Seite
der Ukraine und wenn ich das sage das
hat nichts mit ukrainischer Propaganda
zu tun sondern es ist einfach das
nüchterne durchrechnen von Fähigkeiten
und Verlust haben und ich sage das immer
wieder immer wenn der Krieg schlecht
läuft dann dann kommt die ganze
Geisterbahn wieder hoch von von den
sogenannten Experten und den sogenannten
Verhandlern die dann sagen ach dieser
schlimme Krieg sollen wir jetzt nicht
lieber aufhören und harte Arme Putin er
will doch nur Frieden ja ja genau
ich sage immer wieder natürlich ist das
ist das nicht schön darüber zu sprechen
aber schauen sich hin auf die brutalen
Realitäten des Krieges und fragen sie
sich wäre das alles passiert wenn Putin
nicht angegriffen hätte und dann haben
Sie eigentlich schon die Antwort auf so
etwas ja also natürlich ja im Krieg
sterben Menschen das ist so ähm aber das
ist kein Argument deswegen einem
Aggressor das Wort zu reden jetzt haben
sie gerade noch mal gesprochen von den
mobix sie haben ja auch sozusagen im
ersten Teil ganz am Anfang haben wir ja
über Bach Mut gesprochen sie haben ja
auch das gesagt was ein Kommandeur eben
Tim Kröger ja auch gesagt hat dass es
sehr wahrscheinlich ist dass man eben
von ukrainischer Seite versucht bachmut
über die Flügel vorzustoßen weil doch
die weniger vielleicht hat kämpfenden
erfahrenen gut trainierten russischen
Einheiten der normalen regulären Armee
sind und die Wagner Truppen im Inneren
der Stadt Vorstoß jetzt fragt Jens Erik
kurz noch mal darauf bezogen besteht in
eine reale Chance der Ukraine die
russischen Truppen in bachmut
einzukesseln was würde denn dann
geschehen werden die russischen Truppen
sich ergeben oder weiterkämpfen jetzt
greife ich erstmal auf was sie sagen man
muss ja unterscheiden das eine sind sage
ich mal die regulären Truppen nicht so
gut ausgebildet auf der anderen Seite im
Stadtzentrum wohl vorgestoßen die
wagnertruppen wie schätzen Sie das ein
was sagen sie ihre kurz
also ich denke spätere Historiker wenn
Sie diesen Begriff diesen diesen Krieg
ähm einmal untersuchen werden
wahrscheinlich so etwas sagen wie
Präzision schlägt Masse
Russland für diesen Krieg eigentlich
immer noch wie es wie es im 19 und auch
um 20 Jahrhundert Kriege geführt hat
nämlich mit mit einer brutalen
Überlegenheit an relativ dummer und
unpräziger Masse das heißt also am
massierten Einsatz von von Artillerie
und ähm massierten Einsatz von schlecht
ausgebildeter Infanterie deren Leben
eigentlich gleichgültig ist das haben
sie in der russischen Krieg Führung
immer wieder gesehen und diese Art der
Krieg Führung die stößt nun eben
deutlich an ihre Grenzen weil sie zwei
Dinge nicht hat erstens Präzision und
zweitens Mobilität und beide Elemente
benutzt die Ukraine eigentlich recht
erfolgreich um eben auf eine andere Art
und Weise zu kämpfen und das frustriert
eben die Russen wenn Sie schauen die die
Wagner vorgegangen ist in der Stadt die
schicken zun Wellen also vier bis fünf
Wellen von mobix vor die werden sämtlich
herausgenommen ja weil die haben keine
Überlebenschance und die sechste oder
siebte Welle der gelingt es dann
vielleicht irgendeinen Graben
einzunehmen und diese Position zu
sichern und erst dann rücken die
regulären Wagner Kämpfer nach dir für
Pregarten wirklich wertvolle Assets
darstellen und die opfert er nicht
einfach so hin ähm das ist aber eine Art
und Weise zu kämpfen die nicht nur
verbrecherisch ist sondern militärisch
auch unsinnig die kann also nur
durchhalten solange einen unbegrenzten
Nachschub an diesen untrainierten mobics
erhält deswegen heißt das ganze auch so
schön Fleischwolf von bachmut es klingt
ziemlich ja aber ähm sie haben es hier
nun eben mit einem Berufsverbrecher zu
tun den solche Argumente völlig
gleichgültig sind und sie sehen das was
sie Ukraine auf keinen Fall tun darf ist
sich in diese Art der Kampfführung
hineinzwingen zu lassen also quasi das
gleiche zu tun und zu versuchen
fanatisch die dazu halten es ist mehr so
dass die Ukraine die Energie des Gegners
nutzt und sie gegen ihn wendet und
deswegen sagt okay wir lassen uns auf so
einen symmetrischen Abnutzungskampf gar
nicht ein sondern wir suchen die
Schwachpunkte und die liegen nun eben
nicht in der Stadt sondern an den
Flanken und versuchen dann dort
unsererseits Gegenstöße vorzunehmen ob
es Ihnen jetzt gelingt Wagner wirklich
einzukesseln das ist vor allem eine eine
logistische Frage weil dann müssten sie
wirklich nachrücken mit größeren
Verbänden denn diese diese Flanken die
sind deutlich länger als das eigentliche
Kampfgebiet in der Stadt ich denke
kurzfristig geht's für die Ukraine
zunächst mal darum die
versorgungsstraßen zu sichern also die
t0506 und die ähm die südliche Straße
die von ihrer Nichte hineinführt weil
wenn die beiden sicher sind dann kann
die Ukraine eigentlich beliebig Logistik
nachschieben und dann die Russen weiter
abnutzen in diesem Raum also ich denke
schnelle Erfolge kann man sich da nicht
versprechen aber wenn das stimmt was ihr
Korrespondent gesagt hat dann hat die
Ukraine wirklich in wenigen Tagen
Geländegewinne zunichte gemacht für die
Wagner Monate gebraucht hat um sie
einzunehmen also auch daran sieht man
eben den Wahnsinn dieser Krieg Führung
auf der russischen Seite und das macht
wie Tim Kröger gesagt hat eben
wahrscheinlich auch etwas mit der Moral
der russischen Truppen kommen wir zu
Präsident selensky der war ja nun in den
letzten Tagen auf Europatour Italien
Deutschland Frankreich Großbritannien
und am Wochenende hat Deutschland eben
nun ein gigantisches Paket geschnürt ein
gigantisches Paket an Militärhilfe
zugesagt schauen wir uns das mal im
Detail kurz dieses neue waffenpaket
enthält 30 Leopard 1 Panzer 20 Marder 18
Rathaus Witzen vier Flugabwehrsysteme
200 aufklärungsdrohnen und weiteres
Gesamtwert 2,7 Milliarden Euro
ganz kurz erstmal die Frage 2,7
Milliarden hat es so ein großes Paket in
der Vergangenheit eigentlich schon mal
gegeben
wie sage ich dass diplomatisch also aus
Deutschland nicht aber das will nicht
viel heißen weil Deutschland ja relativ
spät und relativ zögerlich angefangen
hat überhaupt die Ukraine zu
unterstützen also es ist schon mal ein
großer Schritt voran von dem Level ach
wir könnten ja mal 5000 Helme und ein
Feldspital liefern was wir noch vor 13
Monaten diskutiert hatten es klingt
heute so beschämen dass wir uns alle da
sind wir uns alle einig ich verstehe wir
verstehen die Ironie dass die lassen Sie
mich mal dass das kurz in ins Verhältnis
setzen also sie sagen jetzt gigantisch
ich glaube nicht dass das korrekte
Adjektiv ist also Dänemark alleine
liefert 100 Lego A1 aus seinem Beständen
ich denke viel mehr es ist das Nachholen
des längst überfälligen man darf sich
auch von der Dimension nicht täuschen
lassen also 2,7 Milliarden das klingt
jetzt zunächst mal viel ähm aber wenn
Sie schauen was in der zeitenwände für
Hausnummern genannt wurden also 100
Milliarden für die wieder Aufrüstung der
Bundeswehr wenn Sie schauen was die
ganze Welt bisher an unterst
Dienstleistungen geliefert hat in die
Ukraine dann nimmt sich das dann schon
etwas bescheidener aus das soll das
ganze nicht abwerten aber man muss sich
auch klar machen dass man nicht einfach
mit mit solchen PR-Aktionen im Sinne von
wir haben gerade ein riesiges Paket
geschnürt weiter kommt man kommt nur
weiter mit einer kontinuierlichen
Unterstützung und die ist ja durchaus
eingeplant also vom Finanzministerium es
soll ja weitere weitere 8 Milliarden
dann noch kommen bis 2032 und ich denke
das ist der eigentliche Punkt dass man
sich klar sein muss dieser Krieg endet
nicht wenn die Kampfhandlungen enden
sondern wir werden nach wie vor ein
feindliches und ein revanistisches
Russland bekommen an der russischen
ukrainischen Grenze und das bedeutet
dass man die Ukraine natürlich auch
langfristig militärisch aufstellen muss
gegen künftige russische Aggression
ja und das führt direkt zu meiner ja
letzten Frage die wahrscheinlich
wirklich die schwierigste ist Ihre
persönliche Einschätzung ich habe es
eben schon gesagt Sie haben es ja auch
mitbekommen in dem Beitrag von Tim
Kröger ihor der Sanitäter hat gesagt er
Träume wie alle davon endlich nach Hause
zurückzukehren lebend und gesund was ist
ihre Einschätzung wie lange müssen denn
wohl die Ukrainer noch davon träumen
wenn und das haben wir ja jetzt aus der
Ukraine von Herrn Schlegel und von Tim
Kröger gehört ja wohl offensichtlich
doch die große große große große
Mehrheit sagt der Sieg das Ende kann
erst sein wenn wirklich der letzte
russische Soldat ukrainischen Boden
verlassen hat wenn das also der Ziel ist
einer gegen Offensive etc dann ist die
Frage wie sieht es auf einem Zeitstrahl
aus wie lange müssen die Ukraine davon
noch träumen und darauf hoffen
ja sie sagen jetzt das sei die
schwierigste Frage ich sehe das anders
das ist die leichteste Frage stellen Sie
die Frage bitte Herrn Putin in dem
Moment in dem er seine Truppen abzieht
aus der Ukraine ist der Krieg vorbei
Punkt und dann kann Igor nach Hause so
einfach ist das ähm es ist immer wissen
Sie ich ich frage mich immer warum dreht
man immer die kriegsschulfrage um nach
dem Motto wie lange muss die Ukraine
noch kämpfen bis endlich Frieden ist die
Frage ist viel mehr wie lange toleriert
man die russische Aggression noch und
die russische Aggression beginnt
natürlich schon im Prinzip 2014 aber das
worüber wir jetzt sprechen beginnt mit
der Invasion 20 22 das heißt das ist
nicht in der Hand des armen Igor zu
entscheiden sondern entweder sieht Putin
das ein und dann ist der Krieg morgen
vorbei oder er sieht es nicht ein und
dann geht der Krieg so lange weiter bis
er es einsehen muss oder sein Nachfolger
oder pregorien oder wer auch immer dann
in Russland die Macht übernimmt aber aus
diesen harten Realitäten des Krieges
kommt niemand heraus auch nicht die die
jetzt Entwicklungen fordern und damit
Unterwerfung meinen ich denke da ist
doch bei manchen noch ein Update des
Weltbildes weniger lange das so schön
genannt hat erforderlich bis einfach
klar ist dass wir hier nicht mit mit
irgendwelchen Appellen Weiterkommen
sondern dass das eine welthistorische
Frage ist die hier entschieden wird und
die erfordert natürlich
einen gewissen durchhalte werden ich
sage Ihnen aber auch ich kenne keinen
einzigen Ukrainer der nicht die
Wiederherstellung der Ukraine in den
Grenzen von 1991 fordert und das ist
auch völlig berechtigt es ist das
völkerrechtlich einzig legitime
Ergebnisse dieses
dann danken wir ganz ganz herzlich für
das Update was wir eben durch sie auch
bekommen haben und ich glaube wunderbar
haben sich die Informationen die
Einschätzung Schilderungen doch ergänzt
um ein Gesamtbild in gewisser Weise zu
bekommen wir sagen ein großes Dankeschön
merci viel mal nach Zürich vielen Dank
auch an alle die zugeschaut haben die
sich hier beteiligt haben Fragen
gestellt haben und wir danken auch ganz
herzlich für die vielen Herzen für Tim
Kröger und die Frage wie es den Team
geht ich kann es auf jeden Fall sagen
dem Team geht es bestens äh der
Luftalarm hat zu keiner weiteren
Probleme geführt und das Team dem Team
geht es also bestens vielen Dank für das
Interesse das war unser Livestream zur
Frage wann wo die ukrainische Offensive
beginnt wir haben hoffentlich einen
gutes Gesamtbild der Lage transportieren
können vielen Dank für das Interesse
tschüss